oh my gosh you look beautiful beautiful
thank you okay so this song has just
been stuck in my head stuck in my head
can you tell me how you got involved
with this song and what the song means
to you I was really excited around the
end of last year I got a phone call and
I was asked to come down and make a song
for this movie I instantly said yes like
the all I got to begin with it's like a
synopsis of the movie and a trailer and
I said yes to that and then I got to
work with like some of my favorite
songwriters just in transferring Kennedy
and we got to just create something
really special together and Alicia
really stands the loads of marginalized
people and I feel like in the song we
just wanted to be able to kind of just
kind of put out there that you have to
constantly speak up about the injustice
of the world you'll always have to use
your voice you should never stay silent
and that was kind of like the deeper
meaning behind the song that also
relates to the empowering message of the
video moving absolutely and the song is
beautiful all around do you think that
sound is indicative to what we're gonna
hear on an upcoming album no no no it's
completely different this is a
completely separate project and it was
made just for this minute
the names bond James Bond there is a big
strong campaign for you to do a song for
the next Bond film is that any closer to
being around I have no idea I know just
as much as you do I would love to do it
but I haven't I haven't even stopped
thinking about anything else we're
trying to manifest it right now yeah I'm
doing all of that
[Music]